on la grande bretagne qui a
officiellement dit non à l'euro
aujourd'hui pour londres les conditions
ne sont pas réunies mais le gouvernement
de tony blair ne veut pas totalement
fermé la porte à la monnaie unique
un référendum pourrait être organisé
l'année prochaine christelle meyrals
type de paix inde gardons la livre en
grande bretagne les anti euro peuvent
être satisfaits des finances l'annoncé
comme prévu cet après midi devant la
chambre des députés
le pays n'est pas prêt à adopter le camp
d'une blague s'est appuyé sur ses
volumes nous études pour déclarer que
deux des cinq critères fixés par le
gouvernement ne sont pas remplies
l'angleterre n'a pas suffisamment adapté
son économie par rapport à celle de la
zone euro et la flexibilité reste
insuffisant cependant le champ celui
d'échiquier a voulu rassurer les pros
euros et laisse la porte ouverte à l
effet si sur la base des critères que
nous avons définies nous pouvons montrer
sans ambiguïté que le gouvernement dans
l'intérêt du pays
on recommande à la population de voter
oui à un référendum sur l'adhésion à
l'euro et bien si les conditions
économiques sont bonnes alors oui nous
devrons aller cependant au final tout
ceci pour cet éventuel référendum car
l'opposition à l'euro et très fortes
entre régions à l'euro entraverait notre
prospérité détruire et des emplois et
amènerait une irréversible selon vos
propres termes monsieur le chancelier
une irréversible perte de contrôle sur
notre politique économique selon un
sondage 68 % des britanniques voteraient
non un référendum
les habitants comme ici dans l'ouest du
pays sont attachés à la livre elle s'en
va c'est notre monnaie nous allons
perdre tout cela et je ne vois pas
pourquoi nous le ferions si nous
adhérons qu'est ce qui va aussi
disparaître la monarchie notre façon de
vivre
en grande bretagne les milieux
économiques sont les plus favorables à
l'euro une monnaie unique qui
développerait le commerce avec leurs
partenaires européens